ام
مشاهدينا اهلا بكم بينما تتوارد معلومات
عن سعي الحوثيين للسيطره على مضيق باب
المندب قام وزير الدفاع اليمني بزيارته
الى وحده عسكريه في باب المندب
ودعاها لمكافحه التهريب بكافه انواعه
وخاصه تهريب الاسلحه نتوقف مع هذا الخبر
لنناقشه في محورين ما هي اولويات المؤسسه
العسكريه اليمنيه الان في ظل الظروف
الراهنه في اليمن
وهل من استراتيجيه تتبعها الوزاره لمنع
تكرار سيناريو صنعاء في منطقه باب المندب
اذن وزير الدفاع اليمني وحدات عسكريه في
منطقه باب المندب وحثها على مكافحه
التهريب وحث الوزير قواته على اليقظه
والجاهزيه والحفاظ على المعدات وممتلكات
القوات المسلحه وعدم التساهل مع الخارجين
عن النظام والقانون
جاءت الزياره بينما اشار مصدر عسكري مقرب
من الحوثيين قبل ايام الى ان الجماعه تضع
نصب اعينها كهدف السيطره على ميناء
الحديده كمرحله اولى في طريق توسيع وجودها
على طول الشريط الساحلي وحتى منطقه باب
المندب
يضع الحوثيون يدهم على صنعاء يستولون على
سلاح الدوله ينصبون الحواجز على الطرقات
يصبحون بين ليله وضحاها قوه معطله للدوله
اذا شاءوا فلا رئيس حكومه جديدا للبلاد من
دون موافقتهم تلك ضربه استراتيجيه ثقيله
تتجاوز اطارها اليمن الى الاقليم باسره
تهدد وتزلزل وربما تغيير خرائط القوه
والنفوذ في اقليم يمر بمرحله انتقاليه
يسعى خلالها البعض لتعظيم حصه فيها ليست
صنعاء وحسب هي المستهدفه داخل اليمن كما
تقول بعض دول المنطقه بل مناطق اخرى منها
مضيق باب المندب بالغ الاهميه استراتيجيه
فهو عمليا يتحكم بالتجاره العالميه بين
ثلاث قارات هي اسيا وافريقيا واوروبا
اضافه الى اهميته كمبر لنقل النفط المنطقه
او جزء غير هين منه الى الاسواق العالميه
يربط بين المحيط الهندي والبحر الابيض
المتوسط
وبسبب ذلك كان حلم الامبراطوريات في
القرون الوسطى والدول الاستعماريه في
القرنين التاسع عشر والعشرين
وعلى مياهه ظرف الدموع ذوي البحاره الذين
كانوا يغادرون بلادهم ولا يعودون اليها
ابدا فاذا هو بوابه الدموع في الشفافه
والمرويات وفي الايام التي مضت
اصبح كثيرون يتهمون الحوثيين بالسعي
للسيطره على المضيق اعينهم على مين
الحديده على البحر الاحمر ومن بعده باب
المندب يسيطروا على الشريط الساحلي باكمله
امر دفع وزير دفاع البلاد الى زيارته
اخيرا في رساله طمانه لمخاوف خليجيه
متعاظمه وليس معلوما بعد ما اذا كانت
زيارته قد حققت هدفها هذا خاصه ان الرجل
متهم من معارضي الحوثيين بانه سهل سيطرتهم
على صنعاء وانه امر جنوده بالانسحاب من
طريقهم و ما تخشاه دول الخليج ودول اخرى
في المنطقه ان يحقق الحوثيون طموح ايراني
امبراطوريه يداعب مخيله اساسها منذ زمن
وهو السيطره على الممرات المائيه في
المنطقه فاذا ضمنوا السيطره على باب
المندب بالاضافه الى مضيق هرمز الذي
يسيطرون عليه سيتحكمون فعليا بتجاره
المنطقه وب حركه تدفق النفط مع العالم
وتلك لعبه شطرنج يصفها منتقدو السياسه
الايرانيه بانها اكبر من تلك النقله التي
سقطت فيها صنعاء بايدي حسين ثمه قلاع اخرى
تنتظر
موضوع حلقتنا هذا ان نناقشه مع ضيفنا في
الاستوديو الاستاذ الجامعه الامريكيه
الباحث السياسي اليمني اهلا بك وايضا اه
ينضم الينا عبد الحكيم هلال من اه صنعاء
وهو الكاتب والباحث السياسي اليمني في
انتظار ان ينضم الينا لاحقا خلال هذا
البرنامج العقيد محمد عبد العزيز مدير
تحرير صحيفه 26 سبتمبر الناطقه باسم الجيش
نرحب بضيفنا اذن الجمال الملكي والاستاذ
عبد الحكيم هلال ابدا معك من صنع استاذ
عبد الحكيم عندما يزور وزير الدفاع
المنطقه ويقول ان الهدف ومكافحه التهريب
نتساءل ما هي اولويات
المؤسسه العسكريه في اليمن هل اه مكافحه
تهريب اولويه
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم اولا
بالفعل زياره وزير الدفاع باب المندب كثير
عده تساؤلات حول اولويات المؤسسات
العسكريه في اليمن
في ظل هذه الظروف التي اه تحولت فيها
المؤسسه العسكريه اه الى الوجود اه لا
تستطيع ان تدافع عن نفسها وسلم صنعاء بكل
سهوله لكن الحديث عن قضيه التهريب في مثل
هذا الوقت ربما ينظر اليه وخاصه الحديث عن
تهريب السلاح اه ال ال ان الامر مرتبط بما
يحدث في الوطن العربي بشكل عام
فقضيه التهريب هنا ربما لا لا تعلق تهريب
السلاح يتعلق بقضيه التهريب السلاح ي
الحوثيين الى القاعده لان هناك اه حول
المعركه القادمه ستحمل القاعده والحوثيين
وبالتالي هناك ربما معلومات بان السلاح
الى جانب المقاتلين الذين يرون يعني
بعد ان سيطر الحوثيون على صنعاء ومخازن
السلاح فيها وايضا هناك هناك انباء طبعا
عن سيطره مسلحين لا نعرف من هم مسلحين على
مخزن للاسلحه الثقيله ايضا في الحديده
يعني بوجود السلاح هكذا ب ب هذه الكميات
والسيطره على مخازن السلاح وتقول من اجل
السيطره على تدفق السلاح ما زال لم يتدفق
السلاح بعد على الجماعات المسلحه
يبدو ان ضيفنا من صنعاء انقطع الخط معه
السلام الملكي يعني الان عندما يتحدث وزير
الدفاع عن تهريب مكافحه تهريب السلاح يعني
تقرا في ذلك تبسيط للموضوع هكذا ان لم يكن
تد فيها للموضوع هل هو غير مدرك للمخاطر
المحيطه بالسيطره على مناطق حيويه مع
برمائيه مهمه مثل مضيق باب المندب مثلا
هناك اعتقد اكثر من اه نقطه اه من وجهه
نظري ان هذا هو المعلن اه حدث اثناء
الدخول الحوثيين الى صنعاء التقطت الصوره
الذهنيه اولا لوزير الدفاع ووزير الدفاع
اليوم اصبح الكثير من ابناء الوطن
والمواطن البسيط اعتبره بين قوسين قائلا
لانه يعني متهم بتسليم بتسهيل دخول
الحوثيين الى صنعاء يعني هذا ال اه هذه
الصوره الذهنيه اولا لوزير الدفاع اعتقد
انه يسعى لتحسين هذه الصوره الذهنيه وايضا
اه اهتزت اه لدى شريحه واسعه من المجتمع
اليمني السعوديه للجيش نفسه فهو اعاده اه
ربما اه يعني تحسين هذه الصوره التي اهتزت
لاسيما في دخول صنعاء مازال المجتمع
اليمني في اثر الصدمه التي حصلت هذا
التسليم للمليشيات المسلحه التي دخلت الى
صنعاء اه موضوع باب المندب هو سياق اقليمي
واسع يعني هو اه يعني لا نستطيع يعني ما
الذي جعلنا ن نقول انها ان هذا التوجه فيه
منطق اولا ان الحوثي فكر بهذه الطريقه
يفكر بطريقه انه مادام مادام سلاح ليبي
الوصول الى هنا لماذا لا اواصل السيطره
على مناطق اكثر اهميه هو يفكر بهذه
الطريقه لا يفكر بطريقه الاكتفاء ب ما حقق
بالمكاسب لكي يحافظ عليها هو اه يعني
استراتيجيه التوسع ما دام متاحا لانه لا
يفكر بطريقه ان لا يهمهم من يقتل في هذه
المواجهات او بهذه محاوله حتى من ال من من
من المقاتلين معه ولا يهمه اه يعني ماذا
سيقول عنه المجتمع الدولي ثبت يعني يعني
خلال اه ثلاث ايام اه يتم اه التحفظ على
مبعوث الامم المتحده بشكل او باخر في صعده
ليتم دخول صنعاء ثم بعد ذلك التوقيع يعني
هناك حاله من ال استخفاف لان هناك من يقول
ان يجري الحوثيين على ذلك لهم بما انهم
جاؤوا على ما فعلوا سيجرون اه النفي ايضا
النفي الذي تناقلته اليوم وسائل الاعلام
من قبل الحوثيين نحن سمعنا نفي انه لم
يسقطوا امرار وسقطت عمر ان تسقط سلعه
وسقطت صنعاء فاصبح ال اه يعني اصبح ما حدث
على الارض يجعلنا في ذلك ليس هناك فقط
الحوثيون عندما يتحدث وزير الدفاع مكافحه
تهريب هناك الحوثيون هناك القاعده هناك
جماعات اخرى الان الخط الساحلي وهو باب
المندب تعز الحديده خليج عدن وميناء مدى
اصبح مهددا بالاستيلاء عليه من طرف هذه
الجماعات المسلحه هل من قوه رادعه اليوم
لهذه الجماعات كي لا تسيطر على هذه ال ال
ال المناطق الحيويه ان الجيش عندما يريد
ان يفعل شيء من هذا النوع سيفعل واثبت ذلك
عندما واجه القاعده ونجح في مواجهه
القاعده اماكن معينه لكن هناك علامات
استفهام كثيره
هذه علامات الاستفهام في المفارقه في
مواجهات الحوثيين الحوثي يفتح له ويسهل له
بينما القاعده ونحن ضد كل المليشيات
المسلحه بلا استثناء لكن هذه علامات
الاستفهام التي الى الان يعني لا لا
يستطيع احد الاجابه عليها بشكل يقيني
لماذا لا يتم مواجهه الحوثي جماعه مسلحه
تسعى للسيطره على اماكن استراتيجيه هامه
يعني نحن يعني ليس ليس مخفيا محاوله
السيطره على ميناء ميدي يعني باكثر من
طريقه حتى بطريقه شراء الاراضي في تلك
المنطقه من قبل الحوثيين يعني اكثر من
يعني اكثر من معلومات من مصادر خاصه من
ابناء المنطقه انه هناك توجه بشكل ملحوظ
لشراء مناطق قرب ميناء ايضا على البحر
الاحمر يعني هو توجه معروف ليس خافيا لكن
هي علامه الاستفهام التي تشير الان
السبب الاول هو المفارقه في تعامل الجيش
مع الحوثيين يعني اه هناك مفارقه واضحه
انه لا ياتي مواجهه الحوثيين عندما سيطروا
على هذه المناطق الها ما بعد يعني اقتحام
العاصمه والكل شهد ذلك النقطه الثانيه
المجتمع الدولي هناك موافقه ضمنيه شبه
موافقه ضمنيه لما يفعله الحوثيين لم نسمع
الى الان يعني صوتا اه يلقي الى ما حصل
يعني يبدو ان هناك مواطنيه خلينا نحاول
هذا السؤال اللي عبد الحكيم هلال لماذا لم
نسمع صوتا يعني راجعا او قوه رادعه ل اه
هذا التقدم الى الجماعات المسلحه في مناطق
بهذه الحيويه نتحدث مثلا عن ما يحدث الان
في اه مضيق باب المندب على سبيل المثال
من الواضح ان القضيه المؤامره هنا تحضر
بشكل كبير جدا
في سبيل صنعاء والان تسليم سماحه الاحتجاج
في محاوله حقيقه
وتصريحات الحوثيين بانه سيقترب يرفضون
ميناء الفريده
يتقدمون الى باب المندب كل هذا بدون اي
تحرك من قبل الدوله او من قبل الجيش او من
قبل وزاره الدفاع يدل دلاله واضحه على
حضور
فرضيه القضيه او حقيقه المؤامره التي يتم
التحدث عنها دائمه خاصه وان وزير الدفاع
كان في عدم قبل زيارتي الى باب المندب
وزار بعض الاليات في عدم ثم توجه الى باب
الوزاره بعض الالويه وهناك ايضا احاديث
الان وصلتنا وزاره الدفاع سلم في حدود عشر
الف خيمه الى الحراكيين الجنوبيه
في ذكرى 14 اكتوبر من اجل عمل نفس الطريقه
التي قام بها في صنعاء المطالبه بالانفصال
هذا الخيار وزاره الدفاع من المؤسسه
العسكريه هناك مؤامره يشترك فيها وزير
الدفاع بشكل واضح زيارته زيارته الى الى
باب البلده ايضا
صرف
الامطار عن ما يحدث الان او سيحدث قريبا
او غدا او بعد غد في عدم في قضيه المطالب
الانسان وهي المرحله الثانيه من خطه وكما
قلت لك هناك مؤامره واضحه تحدث في اليمن
بدات في تسجيل صنعاء وتسليم الشمال الى
الحوثيين
المرحله الثانيه بتسليم الجنوب الى
الجنوبيين في قضيه المطالبه بالانفصال
وسيكون بعض البلدان الان
حديثه هو
الان كما انهم الحرس الثوري الايراني
الان يستخدمون من قبل الايرانيين
المعروف الملكيين او القدم يكرهون المياه
لا يقتربون المياه
في الجبال
يحدث الان في قضيه التطبيقيه
بعض المدن فهذا هو الذي اه لديه
نعم نسال لماذا هذا التكالب على هذا
المضيق نتحدث طبعا عن مضيق باهميه
استراتيجيه واقتصاديه لعبور النفط ايضا
عبر هذا البند ب ينضم الينا للحديث عن
اهميه الاستراتيجيه العقيد محمد عبد
العزيز مدير تحرير صحيفه 26 سبتمبر
الناطقه باسم الجيش حدث اولا عن الاهميه
الاستراتيجيه والاقتصاديه ل اه مضيق باب
المندب
الحلقه
المرحله
القيمه
عبد العزيز جميل ان توضح لنا اذن الموقف
الرسمي
مما يجري هذه الزياره لوزير فقط سؤال اه
الزياره التي يقوم بها او قام بها وزير
الدفاع اليمني الى المنطقه قال ان الهدف
منها هو مكافحه التهريب هل برايك هذا يعني
يعني مبرر يعني مقنع بالنسبه لاي مراقب
يرى اه اه اه هذا التنافس الكبير على
مضيفه
اه والمعايده اه التي ستلقى
وفي الفتره
عياده هذه الزيارات تقليد عسكري تعارض
عليه اه اه يعني حتى
العامه
طيب الخطيره
وغير غير واضح سوف نعود اليك السيد العقيد
محمد عبد العزيز بعد ان ناخذ فاصل قصير
نناقش بعده اه ما تبقى في الجزء الثاني من
البرنامج اه المخاطر المحيطه باب المندب
نرجو ان تبقوا معنا
مشاهدينا اهلا وسهلا بكم من جديد الى هذه
الحلقه التي تناقش اولويات وزاره الدفاع
اليمنيه في ظل وزير الدفاع اليمني واحداثه
في مضيق باب المندب على مكافحه التهريب
اعود اليك استاذ جمال الملك لاننا فقدنا
الخط مع العقيد محمد عبد العزيز اه يعني
الان ما هي الاستراتيجيه التي يمكن ان
تتبعها السلطات اليمنيه لمنع تكرار
سيناريو اه صنعه في منطقه باب المندب انا
اعتقد انه اه بحاجه الى اه رفع معنويات
الجيش بطريقه عمليه يعني نحن سمعنا كثيرا
وكان الذين بعض الاتصالات اللي بعض
المناطق التي سلبت في صنعاء كان ياتي من
يقول لهم من قبل قياده الجيش لا ت لا اه
يعني لا تمنع الحوثيين من السيطره على
منطقه كذا لا العسكري عندما يوجه له مثل
هذه الاوامر يشعر ب يعني ويصل هذا الي
زملاء وفي كل المناطق يشعر بي معنوياته
خفضه انهم ما الذي يحصل لا يفهم ما الذي
يحصل لماذا الدوله تامره ان لا يوجد
مليشيات مسلحه هذا ال هذا التذبذب و هذا
ال هذه ال هذا العبث بال نفسيه العسكريه
اعتقد انه اخطر ما يواجه اليوم المؤسسه
العسكريه في اذا تكلمنا عن الاولويه من
ناحيه استراتيجيه نحن نتكلم عن الهيكله
التي توقفت بسبب لا نعرف بدات الهيكله
توقفت ولا ت تستكمل بالطريقه التي
تقود الى مؤسسه عسكريه ولائها للوطن اولا
اه للاسف الشديد الكلام عن اولويات مكافحه
التهريب لا يستقيم من الناحيه من الناحيه
المنطقيه هناك اولويات اخرى ما يجعلنا
يعني فكره التركيز على باب المنطق يعني من
خلال التصريحات التي نخوضها قبل الدخول
الاستوديو في في وسائل الفاصل اجتماع
وغيرها هناك من يستبعد القصه ما الذي يجعل
القصه منطقيه هناك يعني الميليشيات
المسلحه علاقه مع الدوله ذات بعد امبراطور
يعني لا يستطيع احد ان ينكر او ان يخفي
البعد الامبراطوريه داخل الفكره السياسي
الايراني وهو الذي رحب واحتفل بسقوط صنعه
واعتبره نصرا استراتيجيا له اذا هناك منطق
لا يستطيع ان نغفل في ال الحوثيين اذا
استطاعوا ان يصلوا سيفعلون لم يمنعهم
الاراده هل هناك هل هل ستتحول هل هناك فرق
بين اه يعني هل ستنظر وزاره الدفاع
والسلطه الجدليه الى موجه الحوثي غير ما
حدث في صنعاء ام سيكون المشهد
لا نستطيع الاجابه على وجه اليقين لانه
اصبح لدي لا شك حقيقي في الاراده لدى
وزاره الدفاع على وجه التحديد في مواجهه
الحوثيين خصوصا طيب اه استاذ عبد الحكيم
هلال يعني نتحدث عن اه معبر اه يعني يعتبر
قناه ما بين البحر المتوسط والمحيط الهندي
عبر قناه السويس
هناك يعني تسابق دوله على السيطره على هذا
ال هذه المنطقه الهيمنه الاستراتيجيه
الدوليه الان اه لاحتواء ما يجري اه ماذا
لو وقع فعلا يعني ال المضيق محل صراع ما
الذي يمكن ان يحدث برايك
هناك تصريحات نشرت في اخر نال خبير عسكري
مصري اه يتحدث عن مخاطر سيطره الحوثيين
على باب على مضيق باب المندب
وخطوره ذلك على مؤثره بشكل خاص يتحدث ايضا
عن ان القوه الخليجيه
او القوى العربيه التي حاربت او كافه
القمه مازالت موجوده في البحر الاحمر وقرب
مضيق باب المندب وانها ما استخدم منرجع
الحوثيين اذا ما يحضروا السيطره او اقترب
اقتربوا من باب المدن بمعنى ان ما بدات
بالحديث عن هذه الاستراتيجيه الدوليه
مبكره هناك ايضا البارجات الامريكيه
والبريطانيه والفرنسيه والعربيه بشكل عام
والايرانيه ايضا متواجده في ضيق بعض البلد
وبالقرب من البحر الاحمر وخليج عدن
المنطقه التي كان كانت مساحه هذه القرصنه
بالنسبه
الخليج ايضا القلق ويجب ان يتحرك الخليج
اللي ردع اي تواجد للايرانيين كما قلت لان
الحوثيين
من الصعوبه عليهم ان يسيطروا على باب
المندب الا اذا كانت هناك حاله شبيهه
بالخيانه التي حدثت في صنعاء وغيرها
المصادر عقيد هذه الخيانه
تقول بمعنى
العقيد محمد عبد العزيز الاستراتيجيه
الاقليميه والدوليه الممكنه في مثل هذه
الحاله
اولا
هناك
اليمنيه
واحد الذي هو المطلوب من
الاتحاد الاوروبي اه
ما جرى الملاح وبابل من اليمن تدرك انه
مجد بل اه الدولي وان السيطره اي طرف او
اي كيان او لا يخدم السلام العالمي
والمساله لن تترك هكذا وانا اه انا اعتقد
اه ان توضع ال الامور وكان وزير الدفاع
يعني هو الكلام الكبير خيانه الرجل اه
يعافي قاتل قاتل القاعده وقاتل التطرف
مراجعه تقريب مساله التهريب وزير الدفاع
هو عضو في لجنه عليا لمكافحه التعليم
وزير الداخليه وزير الدفاع
الصناعه
والجمارك
الاطراف جميعا في لكن محدده
بمهامها
طالب وطالب في اكثر من قضيه طالبهم الوحده
الوطنيه مزيد من الاخوه لمواجهه تحديات
طالب طالب
هذا واضح تماما بالنسبه للوزير والان هل
هل تتوقع تدخلا هل تتوقع تدخلا اقليميا او
دوليا في حال ما اذا سقط المضيق سيد هذه
الجماعه
البحر الاحمر من قناه السويس الى خليج عدن
الى البحر العربيه الى مضيق هرمز الى بحر
العرب هذه كلها
الصحن الدوليه والبارجات الدوليه جميعا
لا تتعدى الامريكي روسيا الصين جميعا
متواجدون في هذه المنطقه لماذا الان نزع
ونتباكى وكان المساله لك انه للعرب سيطره
كامله على البلاد وعلى مضيق باب المندب
اليمن في اطار شراكه عسكريه امنيه تؤدي
دورها التطورات الاخيره هذه قد تكون مقلقه
ل لايران وهذا من حقهم لكن تبحث ايضا
المنطقيه
في اطار معالجه مناسبه هل هناك اعاقه
لمجلس المناحي هناك اه تطورات ام انها
تعليل اعلامي وتهويل اعلامي المساله حتى
اليمن بحاجه الى شيء افضل لمن تعاني من
معضلات اقتصاديه هي يستمر في كل هذه
التطورات في كل هذا الاخلال المجرى
الملاحي الدولي من السويد السويد الى
البحر الاحمر الى مضيق باب المندب الى
خليج عدن اه وموجه من القرصنه وجهت الجميع
ا والامم المتحده هذه في اطار شراكه دوليه
لا يمكن شكرا لك العقيد محمد عبد العزيز
مدير تحرير صحيفه 26 سبتمبر الناطقه باسم
الجيش ونشكر ايضا ان يس تهاجمه الامريكي
الباحث السياسي اليمني اه نشكر ضيفنا من
صنعاء عبد الحكيم هلال الكاتب والباحث
السياسي اليمني بهذا تنتهي هذه الحلقه من
برنامج ما وراء الخبر نلتقي باذن الله في
قراءه جديده فيما وراء خبر جديد لكم منا
اطيب المنى
ام